جنود اوكران الانسحاب من خرسان قد يكون
فخا موقف محرج جديد لبيضن الروس انسحبوا
من الفالوجه ام مصريه تنهي حياه طفلها
بمساعده زوجها الجديد هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
رغم اعلان روسيا سحب قوتها من مدينه خرسون
شككت سلطات الاوكرانيه بهذا الاعلام
متوقعه استمرار القتال للسيطره على
المدينه الكبرى التي استولت عليها موسكو
في بدايه عملياتها العسكريه الرئيس
الاوكراني قال في تصريحات ان بلاده تنظر
بحذر شديد الى اعلان الانسحاب الروسي
مضيفا ان العدو لا يعطينا هدايا على حد
تعبيره فيما قال جنود اوكران يتمركزون
بمحيط خصون ان روسيا قد تحاول جرهم الى فخ
بهذا الاسلحه
من جديد تعرض الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن
لموقف المحرج عندما خلط في حديثه عن طريق
الخطا بين مدينه الفلوجه العراقيه ومدينه
خيرسون الاوكرانيه واصطى تفاعل واسع مع
هذا الموقف على السوشيال ميديا وفي مقطع
الفيديو المتداول يقول بيض ردا على
التحركات الروسيه في خرسان اعتقد ان
السياق هو ما اذا كانوا سينسحبون من
الفلوجه ام لا او اعني ليرد عليها احد
الحضور بالقول خرسانه فيما تاتي هذه
التصريحات بعد اعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انسحاب قواتها من احد المدن الرئيسه التي
سيطرت عليها في اوكرانيا
في واقعه اثارت غضبا واسعا لدى المصريين
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي قدمت ام
بمساعده زوجها الجديد على تعذيب طفلها حتى
فارق الحياه ورمي جثته في احدى او احد
شوارع منطقه عين شمس وسائل الاعلام محليه
افادت بان التحقيقات الاوليه كشفت ان
الطفل البالغ من العمر 3 سنوات تعرض للضرب
والتعذيب على يد زوجه والدته بسبب بكائه
الدائم مشيره
الطفل عبر علاقه غير شرعيه وكانت دائمه
التعدي عليه وفقا لاقوال الجيران فيما
قررت نيابه حبسه المتهمين على ذمه
التحقيقات
الى الاردن هذه المره حيث نقلت سيده تحمل
جنسيه عربيه الى المستشفى في حاله خطره
بعدما اجرت عمليه جراحيه داخل مركز تجميل
لشفط الدهون في عمان نزفت على اثرها لمده
ثمان ساعات ما ادى الى هبوط في الدوره
الدمويه مصادر العربيه نتكشفت ان اجراء
العمليه تم داخل صالون نسائي وليس في مركز
تجميلي مرخص رسميا مشيره الى ان العمليه
تمت على يد سيد الدعت بانها طبيبه جلديه
وتجميل فيما تواصل سلطات المتخصصه توصل
تحقيقاتها في الحديثه
وفي خبرنا الاخير يواصل مالك تويتر الجديد
الين ماسك اثاره الجدل على السوشيال ميديا
اذا كتب في اخر تغريداته او نهفاته كما
وصفها ناشطون ان تويتر سايرتكب الكثير من
الحمقات في الاشهر المقبله على حد قوله
الملياردير الامريكي اضاف ان العصفور
الازرق سيحتفظ بالتعديلات الصالحه ويغير
من لا يصلح منها خلال الفتره المقبله فيما
تاتي هذه التغريده بعد ما الغت تويتر
علامه اوفيشل او رسميه التي اعتمدتها لبعض
الحسابات الموثقه على منصه خصوصا لتلك
التي تعود لاسماء وشركات بارزه